getting on the backboard for an
offensive rebound or brandon clark with
the smaller connington
defending him rob what do you got next
shot the grizzlies take will be their
100th shot of the game
they've made 39 if they shoot 40 percent
they could leave was winners
13.3 again grizzlies have a timeout
remaining
but they do get it in morant drives
finger rolls it up and in for the lead
with 7.3
no timeouts for milwaukee
[Applause]
holiday for the lead puts it in with two
seconds remaining
112 111 and the grizzlies call their
final timeout
john moran got steamrolled partner on
this lay-in on this end
i mean he made the land there were
bodies laying all over the floor we say
he loves her drive from that right side
see there giannis from the back the
contact no call you give the bucks a lot
of credit
because they immediately outlet it to
the to the half court line
and then we said the man who has to make
plays for them and if they're going to
continue to move forward will have to be
drew holiday
well he makes a big play here the little
step back jump shot there
knocks it down 15 off the bench for
holiday
in just his third back third game back
after missing 10 in a row with health
and safety protocol
i mean this is a whale of a move by
morant there to get inside again with
that left hand
never having to touch it with another
hand but
great sense by the milwaukee bucks to
realize no timeouts